so a while ago I got this idea where I
wish I could step into a business and
help them transform help you make
changes to your company to help you
explode and grow and I talked to my team
and I said wouldn't it be a cool idea if
all of us could go in and we could help
an entrepreneur grow and I came up with
this plan they were all on board like
yeah we want to do it want to help out
and so we're launching this contest the
contest is to win me and my team for 24
hours to help you grow we can help you
with your strategy with your website
with your creative with your content
with your pictures whatever you need to
help you grow your business how it's
going to work is whoever wins we're
going to do a quick Google hangout with
you to understand your business
understand your challenges understand
what you need help with understand how
we can be of assistance and then over
the next 24 hours myself and my team are
going to get to work and create
something amazing for you that you can
leverage to help grow your business so
to enter the contest this is totally
free for you guys to enter the contest I
want you to record a video explain your
case let me know why we should pick you
myself and my team are going to review
the entries and then we're going to get
to work to submit your video put it up
on your channel and then create a link
in the in the comments of this video
create the link to your video in the
comments of this video will review them
and good luck I hope it's you I'm
looking forward to working with you
believe